[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
so look puppy but can you see this is
where daddy's going to go gonna go in
climb this mountain yes my name is
Julian Bayliss I'm a conservation
scientist I'm an ecologist my job is to
try and help conserve and protect areas
that are not previously under any form
of official protection I saw this site
through satellite imagery and I've never
ever come across a site like this what
was interesting about this site was the
surrounding land was heavily cultivated
and then the crater containing
rainforest was very dense and intact and
I thought that's a little bit strange
because there should be evidence of
human disturbance today I thought well
maybe actually you cannot get to the
forest therefore potentially this forest
has never had any human interference to
actually find a site with no human
interference gives us this unique chance
to investigate and measure aspects of
climate change
okay and daddy help you the speed at
which climate changes occurring at the
moment there is only one variable that
wasn't there before
and that's the number of human beings
that are on this planet we're planting a
forest up Eddie thanks my hopes of this
expedition - ma'am Rico is that will
help us understand various aspects of
climate change
[Music]
it looks a bit like a volcano it's about
a kilometre across it has a crater it
has a rim and it has a basin of
rainforest it has these very smooth
granite edges that rise up to over half
a kilometre it looks a little bit like a
fortress from dear Zambia Thomas there
everybody welcome to this expedition to
Mount Nebo
you've got a great team together lots of
specialities lots of nationalities young
and old and everything in between the
two climbers Jules Lyons one of the best
free climbers in the UK and Mike
Robinson also one of the best free
climbers in the UK have been rigging the
climb at 125 metres the last couple of
days now and it's basically ready
they're going to finish it off this
morning and then we're gonna start
sending people up so good I think this
is going to be a really interesting
expedition I think it's going to be
really exciting expedition and I'm
expecting to find lots of new stuff new
species hopefully and make this trip
really worthwhile anyway everybody's
welcome thank you very much for coming
let's start working
[Music]
and very nervous about the climb yes
the thought of being alone and exposed
on the rock face is terrifying to most
of the scientists because none of us are
actually climbers the local people know
of nobody in the surrounding communities
who has ever been up to the forest okay
so that feel okay yeah okay
take it you keep doing that for the
patient to be trying their leg live all
the time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay oh wow look at all these beautiful
better place
[Music]
beautiful
very very nice to be as a scientist and
very lucky to be able to visit for these
largely unexplored natural areas such as
these rainforests and to spend time in
them and to see the magic in the beauty
that they have to offer and to show
people
and we can't camp up here unless we find
some water but I know it's from down the
base can there's a massive seepage thing
coming off the cliff over that side so
we can find we can find the source of
that have a camp nearby there should be
good okay
let's go to this faculty up here
[Music]
this would make a lovely campsite look
at it beautiful
nice on the edge nice and open okay
let's set up camp
[Music]
we have the best scientists in the world
on this expedition we have a truly
international and global team
there's nobody being paid for this
expedition everybody here is here is
here because of the desire to conserve
these places exciting
[Music]
climate change will change habitats
[Music]
nothing works in isolation so the
climate changes then the forest changes
the plants change the animals change
when you've got human interference on
top of these habitats it's very
difficult to actually distinguish
between what is actually relating to
climate change and what is actually
relating to human interference so here
we have a very unique experience where
the forest which has had no human
interference and so therefore any
changes that we find among leeko
compared to other forests that we looked
at we'll be down to climate change to
have a good baseline to compare it to so
to be like this is the carbon that
should be in the forest and then compare
that to other sites that are disturbed
we can see effectively what the human
influences and add that to the man-made
climate change part of the equation
because it's not the forests releasing
carbon is us causing the forests to
release carbon
we're looking to maybe through the soil
cause go down go back in history and see
we get some estimation on what the
climate was like maybe a thousand years
ago here we're looking for a history a
bit of a story line between then and now
the other major aspects of this
expedition will be to look for new
species to science put them level with
the soil so what we're doing is putting
in brackets so that we can more
vertebrates so any shrew we get up here
is almost certainly going to be new to
science so any shrew I will be very
excited about the world is full of
secrets and we have not discovered a
fraction of them and the more new
species a particular site has the more
importance
you can then attribute to that site and
that can then leverage was protecting
these sites
[Music]
the idea is to raise a butterfly trap as
high as possible and then you baited
with a fermenting banana mix and that
attracts the canopy flying butterflies
such as your car axis we could find a
new species of Texas that would be as
big as it gets in the butterfly world
that's like finding our new monkey this
time probably tomorrow we'll come back
and we'll have a look at it and I can
almost guarantee we'll have butterflies
in there they are a magical creatures
most the time I just like watching them
we only have a limited amount of time in
the forest on mountain eco to discover
as much as we can it's going to be
intense work
sighs vision
[Music]
I've been lucky enough to find quite a
few new species over the years including
many butterflies and for my daughter's
first birthday I named a butterfly after
her papi Anna Simon Toby Vale aside papi
honor my beautiful daughter papi she's
very inquisitive
so he says daddy's going to the mountain
while daddy's going to the forest so
she's already knows where I am it is a
unique experience to see the wonders of
nature see the magic of nature and for
my daughter not to be able to experience
that would make me makes me very sad it
is a possibility that she won't because
it is possible that these sights won't
be there
they're just being destroyed through
climate change or through human
destruction
[Music]
these animals and plants that are being
forced into extinction
have been evolving over millions and
millions of years to get to where they
are today
and for them to be just destroyed in a
matter of years by ignorance and
shortsightedness makes me very angry
[Music]
antelope it has this big
but this is obviously his part of the
mansion so maybe we put a camera trap
you and the new new species of me but me
yeah there's somebody inside today have
you got something ever we got a mess
true yes
hey that could be our first new species
[Laughter]
discovery every layer of soil is going
back in time and at this point while the
deepest part of this pit is probably at
one point three meters and at the
average rate of deposition around here
we'd expect to be several thousands
years old we were expecting maybe a 30
centimeter sore pit to go back this deep
back in that many thousands of years of
life history of this forest and knowing
that that's been without people is what
it'd be fascinating the results for this
will be incredible and they could
dramatically improve our understanding
of how climate change is affecting our
planet well I'm surprised how many
animals have maybe there are things that
you family and there's antelope we
haven't seen the antelope yet we put
camera traps art but how would an
antelope get affected face this is a
very interesting
[Music]
10 is 5
three of them on the black car axis
which is that group like margarita
another two that are remaining so these
are the infestation
[Music]
of the black corrects this group which
is very interesting group is potential
for this to be new so there's a fair
chance at this but these new species
within these forests you could have all
sorts of medicines and new antibiotics
that we as a human race could actually
use to make our lives more valuable and
richer and healthier a rainforests are
also where 70% of all terrestrial life
is found on this planet
[Music]
what is being lost is disgraceful it's
actually disgusting and I'm almost a
little bit ashamed that and we as a
human race cannot actually gather
ourselves together and see the magic and
the quality and the value of AD these
these habitats actually contain grunty
hopefully the evidence that we generate
the research the new species all of that
we're going to use towards protecting
these sites and conserving them for
future generations
[Music]
is that puppy hello puppy it's daddy
daddy's in the forest on the mountain
I'm having a lovely day on the mountain
thank you copy is I wish you could be
here puppy I think we have it in us to
find a different class
[Music]
I have to believe that it's not too late
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you